Ethan you know once you decided to be an
actor so your first big break movie
loads people love Dead Poets Society huh
and is this movie your children have
seen this film mm-hmm my mother forced
them to watch it in about three-quarters
of the way through my son said so when
do you come on dad when your kids
realize that you're on telly I remember
mine what when she got three or four
running and going mom mom you're on the
telly and I said oh how sweet went in
Teletubbies everyone loves probably you
I mean love he is and he's been on here
and everyone loved him but your your
relationship with Armand that's on set
sounded a bit fractious well he was
incredibly funny right
and he was very relaxed and very
inventive and he would get up and he was
playing this teacher and he would just
improv constantly all day long and the
more the crew laughed the more she was I
hate and I was really wanted to be a
serious actor you know I really was I
hadn't I'd read Stanislavski and I had
what was supposed to be in my pockets
and I really you know really wanted to
be in character and I really didn't want
to laugh and so the more the more I
didn't laugh the more insane he got in
with me funny though this one doesn't
want to laughed and the more smoke would
come out of my ears
he didn't understand I was trying to do
a good job you know I want to be
Montgomery Clift over here you're trying
to be Zero Mostel or something and so I
thought he hated me because he just
constantly would lay into me no sooner
would action start and he would lay into
Todd over here that was my character's
name and and then when the movie was
over I had to go back to school and I
got this call and it was from a big
Hollywood agent you know this guy says
I'm Robin Williams agent and he says
that you're gonna be somebody and then I
should sign you and I was like really
and I so he got me my first agent who
still doesn't know
[Applause]
[Music]